Let's look at the molecular structure
of triglycerides.
In everyday language we often call them fat.
We call triglycerides fat.
Fat is a word from which people are afraid,
but as we will see, fat is extremely important for life.
Fats in liquid form are sometimes called oils.
A more technical term for triglycerides
is a word that you can hear
in the Lekarski cabinet.
Triglycerides are also called -
I will write different parts in different colors.
Triacylglycerol.
Actually I like this name more,
because it is very logical if we divide it into parts,
triacylglycerol.
Triglycerides are fat.
When most people talk about fat,
have in mind triglycerides.
If you check your cholesterol
or if your parents check your cholesterol,
they will probably get a report on their triglycerides,
in which the concentration was measured
of fat in their blood.
Let's think about what triglyceride is.
Here I have the molecules they build
a triglyceride.
This molecule on the left is glycerol.
I will paint it in the same blue,
in which I wrote glycerol.
This is glycerol.
On this side we see that we have three carbon chains.
Each of these carbon atoms is connected
with a hydroxyl group, a -OH group.
If you connect to a -ON group.
you become alcohol,
so that glycerol is alcohol.
Sometimes it's called a triol.
There are three hydroxyl groups here.
And is considered a trivalent aliphatic alcohol.
A trivalent aliphatic alcohol.
We see why there is alcohol, there are hydroxyl groups.
It's also cute.
If you drink the solution on
glycerol, it will be sweet.
You may already have the word glycerol known to you
from the famous Bush song - Glycerine (glycerin).
Glycerin means glycerol.
Glycerin.
♫ Glycerine ♫
So here's glycerol.
Triglyceride occurs when the molecule is glycerol
reacts with three molecules of fatty acids.
These molecules on the left,
each of which is fatty acid.
Each is a fatty acid.
It's a fatty acid, it's another fatty acid,
and this is third.
But why do we call them "fatty"
and why - "heartburns"?
Part of them consists
of these large carbon chains.
I have drawn these points because
the number of carbon atoms may be different.
They may be,
according to my research,
more than 20 carbon atoms.
In most biological systems they have
even number.
And most animals
the number is from 16 to 20 carbon atoms.
We're talking about 16, 18, 20
carbon atoms constituting these fatty acids.
Everyone I've painted has only single links.
We have a maximum number of related hydrogen atoms to carbon.
But there may also be double bonds.
We will pay more attention to this when we talk about
saturated and unsaturated fats.
Here we have a carbon chain.
This part is hydrophobic and will not dissolve in water.
That's why it's called fat.
And on the left,
or at least as I have painted it is on the left,
we have a carboxyl group.
This is a carboxyl group here.
Carboxyl group.
This group is acidic.
It easily gives off hydrogen,
releases hydrogen
or more specifically a hydrogen proton.
If this oxygen atom takes these electrons,
the negative charge can be divided between
this and this oxygen atom.
Therefore, the carboxyl group very much wants to yield a hydrogen proton,
making it acidic.
And that's where "acid" comes from.
Fatty Acid.
These three molecules
should not be the same.
This can have 18 carbon atoms.
This one can have 16,
and this may have 20.
They can also have double bonds.
They may be different.
Thinking exactly how they together form a triglyceride.
Like the 80's robot movies, like Voltron.
What is happening
is a process of organic chemistry -
dehydration.
We have a free e-pair
at each of these oxygen atoms.
These oxygen atoms are part of the hydroxyl groups.
Let me draw it.
We have a free e-pair here
or actually two free electronic pairs.
We have two free electronic pairs here.
We have two free electronic pairs.
If we imagine that
the two molecules meet in the right way,
this carbon here
partial positive charge.
There are three bonds with two oxygen atoms.
Oxygen atoms are highly electronegative.
And if that atom strikes that in the right way,
these electrons can be used
to form a bond with this carbon,
which has a partial positive charge.
When this happens, this connection can be destroyed.
This oxygen says, "Okay, do you participate in another electronic couple?"
"I'm tired of this."
"I will take these electrons for myself"
"or better yet, I will take them for myself"
"and I will attract a hydrogen proton, or I will first draw a hydrogen proton."
It can happen in different ways.
"I will draw a hydrogen proton and become"
"this compound here."
"I will become a water molecule."
This is a very simple description of the mechanism.
You can go into more detail,
when you are dealing with organic chemistry.
And this can happen three times.
It can happen again here.
This atom -
Let's draw it in the same white color.
This atom takes these electrons,
who so much wants to go back and use them,
to grab a hydrogen proton.
It can be the other way.
Maybe it first attracts a hydrogen proton
and when it's gone, that oxygen comes.
There are different ways in which it can happen,
but that's the basic idea.
The same happens for the third time down here.
One of these free electronic pairs
comes and forms a connection with this carbon atom.
With the carbon atom in the carbonyl group,
which is part of this carboxyl group.
And again,
this atom here can take these two electrons
and share this electron pair with a hydrogen proton.
Which again leads to the formation of an aqueous molecule,
a water molecule is formed.
Generally three water molecules are obtained.
So it's called dehydration.
We lose three molecules of water,
to form these links.
What will the molecule look like after all this has happened?
Let him go down
and approaching the picture.
I'll go down.
This green link -
This green link, this is the curved green line here
is this green link.
This second green link
And this third green link is this green link.
As I have painted the molecule now,
none of these oxygen atoms has released its hydrogen atom.
And this can happen before
either after or simultaneously with the other processes we described.
Chemistry is not a very pure science.
But I could, if I want, to paint the hydrogen atoms here.
I can draw hydrogen atoms.
I can paint the hydrogen atoms here,
then these will have a positive charge.
These will have a positive charge.
But you can imagine that
these hydrogen protons become part of another water molecule
and are cleaved from each of these oxygen atoms.
Then we remain
this molecule here.
And remember, we get three molecules of water.
One,
two,
three water molecules.
If we abstain from the water molecules around,
this molecule
is triglyceride.
I'll write it again.
I will write the more technical term,
called
triacylglycerol.
We know where "glycerol" comes from.
There is this spine from
glycerin or glycerol herein.
What does "acyl" mean?
Acyl is a functional group,
in which a carbon atom is part of a carbonyl group.
It may be connected to some kind of organic chain.
Here, I will call it R.
And it's also something else.
And we have three acyl groups, from which comes triacyl.
So this is an acyl group here.
This is an acyl group here.
Each of these is linked to an oxygen atom.
This gives us more exercise options
with another functional group.
When we have a situation like -
I'll take another color.
When we have a carbonyl group
and say just a organic circuit here,
here oxygen,
here another organic chain.
This
is called an ester.
We can see three esters here.
We see this ester.
This ester here.
This ester.
And this ester here.
It was not just an exercise
for fat or triacylglycerol, or triglycerol.
These are different words for the same thing.
We have also exerted all these functional groups.
You now understand the meaning of the name triacylglycerol.
We have a backbone of glycerol
and these three acyl groups,
by which fatty acids are attached to glycerol.
These are the fats people often talk about.
And this is a picture of fat.
This is coconut oil.
It is at a temperature below that of melting,
therefore it is in its hard form.
Below we have a picture of butter,
I'm not sure which, but at a temperature higher than its melting temperature,
so it is in a liquid state.
People call this oil.
But it consists of triglycerides.
Here's a big mixture of triglycerides.
And if we could see their molecules,
they will have this form,
but the fatty acids will have a different number of carbon atoms
and may have a different number of double bonds.